[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear Sarah in
John it's a podcast where we answer your
questions provide you with dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank is
currently in Australia so I am joined
today by my lovely co-host Sarah Urist
green co-hosts in life
yes co-host in life and in podcasts
Sarah do you have a dad joke for us I
sure do
John what did the duck say when he
walked into a pharmacy did he say quack
he said give me some chapstick and put
it on my bill that's good in our family
you really are the person who delivers
the most puns I do I do but not not
regularly I grew up with too many puns
so I try to avoid them well Sarah my
opening bit is to share a piece of good
news of some kind I do listen to the
podcast every once in a while no it's
fine I'm willing to introduce you to
each of the bits as needed I came up
with the joke man I was ready you were
super prepared and I appreciate it this
week in good news Liverpool Football
Club the non third tier English soccer
team that I follow has not given up a
single goal all season long Sarah nine
points from three games a plus 7 goal
differential and for the first time in
living memory a stout defense that is
good news but I feel like it's not
really universally good news for all of
mankind you know it's even better than
kind you know it's even better
universally good news Manchester United
only have 3 points after three games all
right let's move on to some questions
from our listeners ok I will I will
bring us the first question dear Hank
and John this question is actually not
for either of you but instead for John's
wife Sarah because I believe she's a
museum Orchestrator or something like
that anyhow I have a question about
benches in museums how do they work
do they just put them where there's an
empty spot or are they place near in the
direction of artworks that people will
spend more time around we might be
fictive viv this is a great question and
I I have been in my life of
museum curator although I prefer the
term Orchestrator it feels like I would
have more control though as an
Orchestrator a curator is charged with
sort of managing and arranging and
presenting the collection and you know
you think that there'd be a lot of
thought put into where the benches are
but I don't think it's that strategic
actually there are a lot of places you
can't put a bench because people run
into them and there you also don't want
to put a bench in a gallery where
there's a lot of sculpture sitting on
the ground because people can get
confused about what you can sit on and
what you can't so that's another part of
it but yeah you might put a bench in
front of a painting that rewards longer
periods of looking that people might not
stop and take a while with but if you
put a bench there maybe they'll stay and
look by accident just because they don't
want somewhere to sit
but generally in a museum if there's a
masterpiece they will put a bench in
front of it because people want to sit
and stay and look at it for a long time
one of my all-time favorite art projects
this artist named kept behind made
benches that went into art museums but
they sensed when a person was
approaching and ran away that's actually
not quite accurate
but he did make moving benches that
sensed when they were sat upon and then
they'd very slowly start moving oh you
might not notice it but you're sort of
shifting a foot or two to one direction
over the course of in that case Sarah I
have a great idea for an art project for
someone else which is to make a bench
that runs away from the people who want
to sit on it he also made a bench in a
park or actually he made a proposal for
a bench in a park that was near a lake
and when somebody would sit on the bench
a fountain would arise from the lake so
your active sitting activated the
fountain ah
would have been great huh yeah no it's
good all right Sarah we've got another
question this one comes from Katie
who writes Dear John and Hank in May I
graduated from college where I had two
majors one of which was art I had to do
many strange things during my time as an
art student but I found that if I ever
got stopped by campus security for
stealing ivy from the side of the
building or got weird looks from the
building staff as I carried a life-size
alligator sculpture down the hallway I
could always tell them that I am an
artist and all my strangeness would be
forgiven
I wanted to know can I still use this
excuse to get away with being weird and
non art related circumstances if not
some dubious alternative excuses would
be appreciated
ideally making art and being an artist
is such a wonderful excuse for getting
away with weird stuff and I fully think
that if you've ever been an artist or
consider yourself an art maker in any
way you can use that excuse confidently
not that you're making art I'm an artist
just that statement can excuse you from
myriad odd behaviors yeah yeah I've
actually used this excuse one time I was
in a building that I technically
shouldn't have been in and a security
guard approached and told me in rather
terse language that I I didn't belong
there and I was like oh no no no I'm
doing an art project and the security
guard was like what's the project and
then I was in a pickle so I said I draw
circles in dust and then I take pictures
of it over a long period of time to see
when the circle becomes dust again see I
think that's great you've got it you've
got to be prepared though if you're
gonna go out there and say it's for an
art project you have to anticipate that
question whether or not it comes so that
you can answer it confidently this
happens all the time when people are
responding to the art assignments that
we issue through my PBS web series the
art assignment someone responded to this
challenge to become someone else by
changing one thing about you and then
going out into the world though that way
this one person took off their shoes
just walked down the street barefoot
just a city sidewalk filled with people
and you know it's got to be really
uncomfortable but the whole time that
person was fully prepared to say this is
for an art project
so yes being an artist is totally an
excuse for eccentric behavior but don't
harm other people and actually don't
trespass even though I was trespassing
do as I say not as I do this next
question comes from Sarah not my wife a
different one who writes Dear John and
Hank when do I tell someone they've
already told me a certain story before
actually maybe this is from my wife one
of my good friends
aka my spouse is sometimes completely
frustrating to talk to because he tells
me the same stories over and over again
even if I mentioned politely with a
small laugh oh ya know you've told me
that one before he just keeps going and
tells it again should I just let him
tell it even though I'm sick of the
story should I try and change the topic
when I see the story starting should I
just not talk to this person anymore
there's two parts to this answer really
first you must know that John retells
stories all the time and as his life
partner when or in social situations I
know when it's happening like we'll be
we we got together with some neighbors
and you started telling a story one of
your classics and I knew I knew before
but what'd you write me I didn't in that
scenario but it's so you know sometimes
you can do it usually I'll be like oh
he's probably told you that one before
and then you'll respond by maybe making
it brief so that they don't have to be
embarrassed and say that oh yes we
remember but for this thing this person
sounds pretty odd to not not get the
hint like if you're telling a story and
someone goes oh yeah I remember most
people stop yeah but I mean once you're
starting to tell a story Sarah you've
got this momentum and it's hard to stop
the momentum all at once just because
the person you're telling the story to
happens to have heard it 500 times
before I can cut I kind of get where
this person's coming from but the thing
is ostensibly you started telling the
story because you were in a conversation
and that conversation ostensibly has two
equal partners or more if you're in a
larger group and so you told the story
to make a point so when you start
telling the story and someone says ya
know we've heard that one before
you just skip straight to the point
right you say I bring it up because but
I I have a proposal what if the next
time it happens you jump in and say let
me try to tell it this time oh that's
good
I think in short you cannot let this
person get away with it they must note
this is not appropriate behavior
yeah it's probable to those things that
you need to tell them and kind of teach
them I know that when I was younger I
had friends who actively taught me how
to engage socially with other people and
I found it super helpful and I'm sure
they felt awkward being like John you're
standing way too close but it was
actually really helpful for me to
understand that I was standing too close
to people so I wouldn't be afraid to
bring it up although obviously be
generous in doing so that said Sarah can
I tell you the story of how I became the
boxing reviewer at Booklist magazine
okay our next question comes from
Rebecca hey pals I eat eggs every
morning for breakfast and I've been
saving the cartons for a long time what
should I do with them they're currently
stacked on top of my fridge as shown in
the picture below okay so you can't see
this picture but I can describe it to
you it's it's a refrigerator a pretty
standard and there's a lot of magnets on
front and then on top is a very large
almost to the ceiling stack of I believe
there's styrofoam egg carton containers
I would estimate that there are 1200 egg
carton containers on top of this
person's refrigerator I think that's
inaccurate however it is impressive um
so here's my recommendation I think you
already have a pretty good thing
happening there I think you have a
curiosity in your kitchen if you
entertain I'm sure people ask you about
it what I would do is kind of use the
refrigerator more as a pedestal
appropriate to an artwork by clearing
away the other business around it I'm
not sure what that is but I think if you
cleaned up around it and treated it like
it's already an artwork that would that
would do the trick
John what do you think I think this is
at minimum 600 styrofoam egg containers
I just did a quick count of
ten of them look like I'm zoomed way in
okay and I think it's at least it's at
least 400 it could be 600 it could be
1200 this person has a lot of egg
cartons on top of their fridge I love
the idea of turning it into a sculpture
I think it already is a sculpture it's
just not yet properly displayed well you
could move it I would I would keep it as
it is I think it was formed naturally
you know it's somewhere convenient for
you to continue to add to and you need
to keep adding to it obviously so you
could move it to an adjacent room maybe
to a living room if you have sort of a
spot on a table but I think it needs to
be here you just need to clean up around
it eventually
Rebecca you may find yourself in a
situation where you need a you know kind
of whole room to devote to this
sculpture or at that point it stops
being a sculpture it really becomes a
project like I've kept to every egg
carton from every egg I've ever eaten I
think it becomes less a project and more
a problem okay so we have a question
from fourteen-year-old Mia who writes
Dear John and Hank I enjoy being out of
the house and doing things however most
of the things I like to do such as
swimming at the lake or visiting my
local deli or going to the park are only
enjoyable when I do them with friends
otherwise I feel depressed and almost
pathetic the problem with this as I'm
sure you've already figured out is that
my friends cannot always be there what
are some things I can do by myself while
I'm out of the house I really like this
question and it takes me back to a
different period in my life where I had
some lonely times because I'm never
alone now when you have children any
work unit you're never alone anymore
which is which has its positives and
negatives but I vividly remember as a
young younger person spending much more
time by myself
and I had a lot of social anxiety when I
would go out and do things and be sort
of acutely aware of everything I was
doing as if everyone was watching me
so like part of it is just trying
to become more comfortable being by
yourself I think like you can still go
to the park and sit on a blanket and
read and bring some snacks and enjoy
yourself so part of it I think is just
enjoying what you're already trying to
do or what you want to do obviously you
can't like play ping pong by yourself or
something like that I can actually stand
does oh really
yeah he has a little machine that
distributes the ping pong balls to him
in a randomized fashion stan has gotten
so good at ping pong we got a ping pong
table at the office and everybody was
about as good as everybody else which is
what made ping pong fun and then Stan
started taking classes Stan and Mark
started taking classes from a
professional instructor and now it's not
fun at all they just slam it every time
way far out ahead of all of us but I
think the other approach to this is to
go do an activity where you're with
other people but it's not like a blind
date kind of situation where maybe you
join a co-ed ping pong League yeah I'm
gonna make a slightly different
recommendation than joining a co-ed ping
pong League although I'm sure there are
great ones out there which is to go to
youtube and search how to be alone and
watch one of my all-time favorite
YouTube videos and it really is a
beautiful introduction into how to be
alone it's such an important skill and
life I think that it takes some time you
don't start out being good at being
alone but you can get good at it and it
really dramatically increases your sense
of self-sufficiency and your awareness
that in any given moment you can be okay
so I would really go we'll actually post
it to the patreon at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John you don't have to
donate or anything to see the patreon
also we'll post the refrigerator and the
egg carton sculpture one other thing
that you can very easily do by yourself
is go see art actually you can go to
museums that's something where I prefer
to be alone you can go your own pace I
mean I do like kind of museums with you
John know it's going let's definitely
look very offended no it's fine I like
going to museums alone - actually there
is something
wonderful about it because you are your
own boss when you're in a museum by
yourself when you're with a person you
always have to be conscious of where
they are in relationship to you like am
I really fast am I really slow are they
reading all the labels you can do
whatever you want okay this next one
comes from Kate dear Hank and John what
do you think is the most important
advice a parent can ever give their kids
for future parents of course is it not
to lick their knives because I still do
that and have never cut my tongue any
dubious advice for little kids is what I
ask for is it fate
no it's Kate yeah that's a good name
specific sign-off Kate I think the most
important piece of advice I have given
my children is eat your food your
parents have worked hard to provide you
with this food eat it does that work for
you John no it is not effective but who
doesn't like pizza like who do you how
do you put pizza in front of a person
and they think like pizza I don't know
there's a lot of sauce sorry what was
the question okay the first thing that I
thought was wipe from front to back
great advice and tremendously important
Kate we are at a point in our lives with
our children where most of the advice is
fairly straightforward yeah but what you
need to focus on I think is telling them
things that aren't obvious like most
things they need to figure out for
themselves like like looking at you for
example you learn that on your own so I
think the wipe from front to back
because of its involving bacteria and
invisible forces that that is relevant
but for the most part I think they gotta
figure it out for themselves yeah I mean
in the end all you can give your kids is
a set of values hopefully and a fairly
stable childhood hopefully all right
Sarah we got another parenting question
this one is much harder though Dear John
and Hank I did a 21-day Knowles course
in the Wind River Range in Wyoming this
summer my boyfriend sent me letters to
be received at the end of my trip
and they were very sweet and had
personal information in them I've been
home for a while and found out that my
parents read these letters I'm
questioning a lot now like have my
parents been going through other stuff
of mine I'm wondering what you would do
in this situation
thanks Maya Maya you've got to be more
careful with your letters I mean I
remember I used to hide things I would
hide them in like a jacket pocket in the
back of my closet I had a lock box it
was a little extreme but I don't think
you can trust anyone you live with to
not look at juicy materials such as
letters from boyfriends I do not plan on
reading our kids personal mail however
you just you you've got a you've got to
protect yourself here I do not agree I
think that look Maya teams to me there
are two possibilities one possibility is
that your parents did something they
really really should not have done this
is not Maya's fault that she was in the
wilderness for 21 days while her
boyfriend was sending her mail there's
no way that she can lock it up when it's
coming into a mailbox oh I see it now
yes this is a gross violation okay thank
you I'm glad that we came to the same
place the other possibility is that your
parents have serious concerns about your
welfare that they feel are justified and
that justify this violation of your
privacy
that you might hurt someone else that
you might hurt yourself if that's the
case then that's why they did it it's
still not great in my opinion right Maya
I apologize for my earlier advice I I
don't do lock up your letters do you
lock up your letters if you have already
received them but in this scenario I
think you have to talk to your parents
about it hopefully you already have
beyond just your blind fury upon
discovering that they had already read
them I think you can ask them why they
read them and say that you feel
disrespected and that you would hope
that they don't do that again yeah it's
a tough one and luck lock him up
you got to lock it out I also hid
letters as well as cigarettes in a
jacket pocket in the back of my closet
when I was in high school maybe it's not
such a secret spot after all well in my
case it certainly wasn't because one
time my mom like came downstairs after
being in my room and she said just so
you know you're out of cigarettes
great Sydney brutal nice and I was just
like what huh what are you I don't smoke
I really don't know I quit
many years ago actually when Sarah and I
first started dating I was still using
the Nicorette yes and he's probably
gonna bring up a story that you've
already heard before about said
Nicorette you know I quit smooch Sarah
do you know I quit chewin Nicorette I do
[Laughter]
so my boss a book all right
and that's how you stop a story you've
already heard before from happening
that's right that's right you just need
to be like no no no no no no no okay our
next question comes from Carrie I am a
Sunday school teacher in Texas and many
parents want their kids to show respect
by using titles with names I don't want
to be Miss Carrie it sounds too much
like Miss Carrie the substitution of
Miss C does not work for me because it
sounds like Missy going by my last name
is too formal and MS doesn't really make
any of that better do you have thoughts
on how to handle this I really wish this
wasn't a thing I'm fine with kids
calling me Carrie it is my name but I
want to respect their parents wishes
carry on carry off this is actually a
tough one I cannot think of a solution
yeah the only solution I thought well I
had to the first one is to have them
call you by complete first and last name
which is admittedly very weird but it is
an option like Carrie McGillicuddy
who is Jesus I don't like that solution
at all the other solution in my mind is
just to have them call you Carrie and I
know you want to respect their parents
wishes but I think this is this is your
classroom and and you make that call
have you considered Mademoiselle I'm not
sure that works but good luck to you
carry the other thing that you could do
of course is just start going by misses
and when people say like where's your
spouse you can be like oh no it's not
like that okay Sarah we couldn't find
our way through that one but maybe we
can find our way through this one this
question comes from Anders who writes
Dear John and Hank recently I was
writing a sentence as one occasionally
does and it contained the phrase a once
over this is an issue because o is a
vowel unless I've been lied to my entire
life and that should mean that a once
over should be an once over right I'm
desperately in need of your highly
academic and articulate explanations
alive until I'm not Anders okay so I
feel like this question would be better
directed toward a linguist of some sort
than than us Sarah Sarah if we only
answered questions that we were
qualified to answer this podcast would
have ended years ago oh I forgot I
forgot sorry I am admittedly not a
linguist but I do think I know the
answer to this question which is that
once well it begins with an O in the
alphabet actually begins with the sound
wah which is a consonant sound so we say
a once over just as ubiquitous begins
with a u but actually begins with a yuh
which is more of a consonant sound so we
say a ubiquitous I can't use words in
sentences which reminds me that today's
podcast is brought to you by ubiquity
ubiquity I think it means like real
common
this podcast is also brought to you by a
life-sized alligator sculpture you're
carrying down the hallway under the
guise of being an artist what I'm an
artist and today's podcast has
additionally brought to you by at least
400 egg cartons at least 400 egg cartons
that's thousands of eggs and lastly this
podcast is brought to you by your local
co-ed ping-pong league it's a great way
to not be alone we also have a real
sponsor today audible so Sarah and I
have both been listening to the same
book on audible this month it's called
how to raise an adult and it's a really
interesting book yeah it's by Julie lip
got Hames and it's about how to break
free of overparenting your child yeah
it's been honestly kind of life-changing
for us highly recommended but of course
audible has lots and lots of great books
they have all of my books for instance
you can start a 30-day trial and get
your first audiobook free right now by
going to audible.com
nor a double com
slash Dear John I recommend audible.com
slash dear John you can also text dear
Hank or Dear John - 500 - 500
that's audible.com slash Dear John or
text Dear John - 500 500 okay our next
question comes from Cassie Dear John and
Hank I am a generally shy and quiet
person and haven't lived in my city very
long my birthday is coming up and
something I would like to do is have a
coffee and chat with a person who is a
new friend of mine but who I don't know
very well I feel this would be a nice
birthday activity for me
the difficulty is I don't want my new
friend to feel weird that I'm asking to
spend birthday time with them they might
feel that this overstates the friendship
or feel bad that I don't have other
better friends to hang out with I don't
think my friend is aware of my birthday
but they could find out through Facebook
can I ask my friend for coffee and chats
on my birthday or should I stay quietly
indoors and wait for another day manners
and planners Cassie oh I think you
should totally ask this person out for
coffee on your birthday for sure 100%
and I think you can even say look you
know I'm new in this city I don't have a
lot of friends I don't want this to be
weird it doesn't have to be an
over-the-top birthday extravaganza
Enza but really all I'd like is to go
out for coffee yeah every everybody has
friends they like more than they see
Cassie and I think that this is a friend
you like more than you see and I bet
that you are a friend that they like
more than they see so they'll probably
be psyched and kind of honored at least
that would be the hope and if they're
not forget them yeah exactly I think you
can even if you want to sort of mitigate
the awkwardness at all you could say
look it's my birthday coming up and I've
got a whole bunch of things I want to do
I want to go see this movie I'm gonna go
buy this bakery and get a fat slice of
cake for myself
and I'd also love to have coffee with
you are you available hmm I think you're
overcomplicating it just saying when I
have coffee John's probably right okay
all right Sara before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I do hope you have prepared
some Mars news I have oh that's exciting
did they find that Rover wait don't
don't spoil it
first let's answer this question from
Randy who writes Dear John and Hank how
can I tell if I'm chewing my snack too
loudly I work in a relatively quiet
office and every time I'm munching on my
1:30 p.m. snack it feels like my chewing
is the loudest thing in the room I try
to choose slowly but somehow it feels
like that just draws out the sound
should I do rapid ly at a higher decibel
level or slowly and more quietly but for
a longer period of time
do I need to invest in quieter snacks
did I just come up with Hanks new
business venture I'd rather eat Randy
so Randy could you perhaps go outside to
have your snack if you're if you're
feeling a little self-conscious about
your noise level I think that's one
option yeah if you've got the kind of
workplace where they let you outside for
15 minutes to enjoy a snack I was
picturing some kind of like high-stress
work environment where everybody's going
hard all the time and Randy's just like
trying to get a Cheeto when he has a
chance no it sounds like a very quiet
work environment where somebody is
really gonna notice eating Cheetos at
1:30 so what I would do in this
situation probably is right before I
open the bag of Cheetos I would just
announce hey guys it's me Randy it's
1:30 p.m.
I think we all know what time it is
oh not have a very good [ __ ] chewing
noise this does remind me of one of my
favorite children's books that our
children have called violet and Winston
Oh such a good book there is a story
within it called the noisy eater and
violet and Winston are having a picnic
and he's eating his food extremely
loudly and and violet can't take it
anymore and says please save me you
can't eat that peanut brittle so loudly
and he says sure I was almost done
anyway you should have told me and then
he falls asleep and starts snoring very
loudly violet and Winston is an adorable
book Randi I think that you're probably
worrying about this too much I think
this is probably not a big issue I think
probably most people in the office never
think about you and your snacking Sarah
is shaking red no I don't think that's
the case Randi I think I think they can
hear you're crunching if you can hear
you're crunching that loudly and I I
think I think you should either invest
in quieter snacks or you could ask them
Randy I think that you are probably
concerned about something that is not a
concern and that you are worrying about
something that none of your co-workers
ever think about and that you never hear
the sound of them chewing their snacks
because you're not living inside of
their bodies so I think you're okay
if somebody comes up to you and they're
like hey Randy quick question violet in
Winston style and they're like hey Randy
is there any way you could chew those
Cheetos louder then you've got an issue
but until then I think you're good or if
you really want some dubious advice you
can leave an anonymous questionnaire for
everybody office right is there a
whiteboard somewhere where there's like
a lot of physics problems and you can
just circle the question can you hear
Randy's Cheetos no I don't think it
should be handwritten because that would
probably out Randy transfer question ask
send out a survey monkey yes exactly
all right Sarah it is time for the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I will go first because I have
terrible news
oh no that's very
the product the thing about AFC
Wimbledon the season Sarah and you know
this because I've talked to you
repeatedly about it despite the fact
that I I think four games into the
season you've probably heard enough AFC
Wimbledon talk for the entire season
the thing about Wimbledon this season is
that they're playing great the passing
is so crisp and clean there is a little
bit lacking in the final third but
they're playing really well it's just
that lately they are not getting the
results that they deserve it's been so
frustrating AFC Wimbledon played West
Ham in the care about cough West Ham is
a Premier League side Wimbledon scored
in the first minute a Joe Piggott
beautiful header on a corner kick and it
looked like maybe they were gonna find a
way but then they got a red card which i
think was from a dive but that's neither
here nor there they ended up losing 3-1
also Wimbledon lost to Sunderland two to
one even though the referee missed an
obvious penalty and red card absolutely
no ambiguity about it and Wimbledon lost
3-1 to Walsall as I talked about last
week so three losses on the trot but
three games where we played really well
so just frustrating I'm sorry to hear
that John that sounded as sincere as you
usually sound when I talk about AFC
Wimbledon I do believe in AFC Wimbledon
I do like them yes I will say that you
believe in them I don't know that you
need to follow the week to week results
with the level of passion that I have I
think you have enough passion for the
family it's awesome I love it
what's the news from ours okay so today
I bring you news from the Mars
corporation I think you might know okay
so you know them as the thirty-five
billion dollar global business empire
they're based in McLean Virginia their
products include of course candies like
Snickers and skittles and of course Mars
bars but also Altoids I didn't know that
and Uncle Ben's rice and tasty bite the
big thing I discovered was and they are
in the veterinary care business also
they own vca animal clinics and also 20%
of the US market
pet food with brands like AIIMS Eukanuba
and wiskus really they do and there's
usually very little news from Mars
corporation because they've long been
silent and private about their inner
goings-on but recently they've opened up
a little bit and there are still run by
a member of the Mars family Steven
badger great-grandson of founder Frank
Mars and he's currently the chairman of
the board anyway so now that they're
being more open they're sharing their
goals for the corporation and they have
pledged to reduce sodium by an average
of 20 percent in their product lines by
2021 and they want to ensure all new US
products meet added sugar guidelines and
are appropriately labeled and also the
biggest news from the Mars corporation
is that they have cut carbon emissions
from their 150 factories worldwide by
67% and you'll also like to hear that
all of its M&M production is powered by
renewable energy so you know I learned a
lot about the Mars corporation today um
and you know I don't know that I'm
better for knowing it but it is some new
knowledge that I have that I am now
sharing the biggest surprise for me I
have to say is that the Mars corporation
is named for a person who had the last
name Mars not for the planet indeed well
congratulations to Frank Mars and his
great grandson mr. badger is that
correct
Steven badger as in the animal yes B ID
ger well that's wonderful I am as you
know Sarah a longtime fan of their
brands mostly the human food brands
Sarah thank you so much for parting with
me it was really fun thank you for
having me I loved it and thanks to
everybody for listening
Hank we'll be back next week although I
have to say Sarah that was such a joy I
would love to make stuff with you more
regularly this podcast is edited by the
ubiquitous Nick Jenkins our head of
community and communications is Victoria
von Giorno the podcast is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
the music that you're listening to right
now and if
beginning of the pod is by the great
gunnarolla thanks again for listening
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]